thank you to ancestry for supporting pbs
i don't know about you but i'm never
thrilled to go to the doctor
needless sickness injuries and that
crinkly paper they make you sit on
but the worst part is the inevitable
headache of trying to pay
for the visit the american medical
billing system is like
putting salt in our metaphorical wounds
it's standard to have no idea of what a
procedure will cost when we agree to it
then six weeks later this piece of paper
written in an
alien language appears to inform you
that you owe such and such for such and
such and how would you like to pay for
that
if we want to engage productively with
our health care system
we need to have a basic understanding of
what's going on behind the scenes
only then can we protect our health as
well as our pocketbooks
when measured by gdp the us is one of
the wealthiest nations on earth
so it's understandable that we as a
group might pay more for the health care
we receive
but when you compare what we pay as a
ratio to our gdp
to other similar countries we are an
outlier
we pay far more for our health care than
the size of our economy would suggest
there's no shortage of theories as to
why that is
issues like defensive medical care
bloated administrative costs higher
doctor pay and drug prices
all contribute but when you start
sorting through the
mound of complicated data it's really
hard to single out a clear
villain many healthcare experts believe
that the main reason our spending is so
high
is because the price is high don't get
that confused with the
cost the cost of a good is the expense
required to make and provide the service
the price is the amount that the
customer is willing to pay for it
in layman's terms the cost of our health
care actually isn't unreasonably high
but the price markup is normally a
seller's market occurs when demand
exceeds supply this results in an
increase in competition which drives up
the prices and allows the bulk of the
pricing power to be wielded by the
seller
theoretically a free market economy
could balance this by allowing consumers
to not buy the product outright or buy
their products elsewhere
and this happens to a degree in the form
of medical tourism
but for most of us flying to mexico or
thailand for a medical procedure
simply isn't an option and as for
foregoing medical care completely
good luck with that a critical factor in
keeping it this way is a criminal lack
of pricing information
think about it when do you finally know
how much your care costs you not till
weeks after you've already bought it we
also typically don't pay for it directly
ourselves
thanks to insurance companies medical
pricing sheets are traditionally
disclosed
only to them and not the consumer
imagine if you wanted to buy a house but
you couldn't see the listing price
before closing
only your realtor working on commission
is allowed to see the price in advance
that's basically what's happening here
the way
other wealthy countries even those with
large private insurance companies have
dealt with this
is through government regulation but for
the most part the u.s
has completely stayed its hand stanford
economist victor r fuchs said it this
way
governments usually eliminate much of
the high administrative cost of
insurance
obtain lower prices for inputs while
keeping tight control
on the number of specialist physicians
and expensive technology
in the united states the political
system creates
choke points for diverse interest groups
to block or modify the government's role
suddenly this whole mess and political
hullabaloo makes a lot more sense
the one large exception to this is
medicare which is a government program
that covers medical costs of those over
65 and some younger folks with
disabilities
this accounts for just under 20 of the
entire u.s population
so it shouldn't come as a surprise that
when you have that much
medical care to negotiate for you can
create some
serious leverage a recent study showed
that the same service
at the same facility would have cost a
privately insured person
two and a half times more than one
covered by medicare
now other than voting and calling our
representatives which you should do
we don't have a ton of individual sway
when it comes to changing things at the
top
but we do have more power than we think
when it comes to the bills that show up
in our mailboxes
this is kiera and she's what you might
think of as an
extreme couponer when it comes to
medical costs
let's see what we can learn by following
her when she got hired at her new job
she sat down to compare the costs of
three separate plans available to her
she was a bit confused as to what each
plan actually
covers so she called her hr department
for a little guidance
this is a critical step though medical
benefits are really
important to people most don't actually
understand what their policy does or
doesn't cover
how can you effectively use something
you don't understand
now it's time to make a plan for urgent
and emergency care
urgent care facilities are for medical
needs that can't wait to see a physician
like a dog bite but
aren't immediately life-threatening the
er should be used for life-threatening
needs
these visits can get expensive in a
hurry with the average er visit clocking
in around two thousand dollars
kira checks out google maps and calls
two to three places that are closest to
her house
to see if they accept her insurance now
they're entered into her phone
so she can easily speed dial them if
anything should happen
third kiara never accepts a medical bill
at face value
every time she goes to the doctor for
anything more than a checkup
she calls and asks for an itemized bill
just to see if the things she's being
billed for
actually occurred billing errors are
frighteningly common
experts estimate medical billing errors
to be present
75 to 80 percent of the time
fourth she actually shops around for her
care
for non-urgent procedures she spends
some time on websites like
healthcarebluebook.com or fairhealth.org
these sites are like the kelly blue book
for medical care
giving her average prices for things
like tests and procedures
kiera compares the prices and even calls
the hospital ahead of time to settle on
it
before she walks in the doors that's
right you can actually negotiate
directly with a hospital
ahead of time sometimes she finds
herself looking at a bill for a
procedure she
couldn't shop for but many larger
institutions like hospitals
actually have medical billing advocates
on staff to help
patients but you usually have to ask for
them
and if kiara's experiencing a financial
hardship or was without insurance for a
season
simply mentioning this can help knock
down the price
there are even independent third-party
advocates that you can hire
yourself which may well be worth it if
you're facing an especially large bill
if navigating all this feels
overwhelming and unfair
you're right it is our medical system
can leave us feeling powerless and lost
but
just because we might feel powerless
doesn't mean it's totally true
if the system treats us more like
consumers and not patients
then let's take every opportunity we can
to be the savvy shoppers
we know we can be and that's our two
cents
thank you to ancestry for supporting pbs
was that your great grandmother keeping
the family together
was that your great-grandfather paving
the way for change
did they brave mother nature and walk
away stronger
did they face the unknown with resolve
and triumph
there is strength in every family story
ancestry can help you learn about yours
visit ancestry.com for more information
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
if you're young and think you can skip
health insurance you
might want to check out our previous
video on the topic